ما يزال هدف الطرفين المتقاتلين في
السودان هو السيطره على العاصمه فمن يحسم
المعركه فيها يحسم الصراع بنسبه كبيره
لصالحه لكن تركيز الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع على الخرطوم الكبرى لا يعني سعي
الطرفين لتعزيز المكاسب في مناطق البلاد
المتفرقه خصوصا في الغرب فهناك تتسع دائره
المعارك بالتوازي مع عزل رئيس مجلس
السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان لنائبه قائد
قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدانو وتعيين
رئيس الحركه الشعبيه لتحرير السودان مالك
عقار بدلا عنه وما بين حميتي وعقار ما صنع
الحداد من تاريخ طويل من القتال منذ ايام
الحرب في دارفور في الاثناء تدور المعارك
على امتداد الخارطه في نيال عاصمه ولايه
جنوب دارفور اشتباكات طاحنه بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع وجغرافيا يتقاسم
الطرفان مدينه نيالا ففي شرقها تتمركز
قوات الدعم السريع فيما يحضر الجيش في
محيط مقر قيادته في الناحيه الغربيه
للمدينه غير بعيد عن نيال شهدت مدينه
زالينجي عاصمه ولايه وسط دارفور اشتباكات
ضاريه بين الطرفين وشمالا الى الفاشر
عاصمه ولايه شمال دارفور لم تسلم هي
الاخرى من الاشتباكات وتتحدث المصادر من
داخلها عن سقوط قتلى والجرحى واعمال حرق
وتوقف للخدمات الصحيه لكن توافقا مؤقتا
بين سكانها وحركات مسلحه الناشطه في
المدينه يبدو انه ادى الى توافق لوقف
القتال وان كان هشا ولا يعرف حتى الان مدى
قدرته على الصمود اما في مدينه الجنينه
عاصمه ولايه غرب دارفور فوصف حاكم الولايه
الوضع فيها بالكارثي حيث ادت الاشتباكات
الى تشريد الالاف الى تشاد ومع اتساع رقعه
القتال في الغرب ومناطق دارفور تحديدا
المعروفه بانها خزان الدعم السريع ومعقل
قوات حميتي فان الحرب في السودان تاخذ
منحا مختلفا ينذر بنبش تاريخ من الصراعات
في الاقليم المنكوب